السيده الرئيسه السيد نائب الرئيس اعضاء
المحكمه انه من دواعي شرف العظيم ان امثل
امامكم مره اخرى وان امثل دوله
اسرائيل تم الحديث عن عدم انطباق او
الافاء بالشروط الخاصه بدب الاحترازيه
وبالتالي ليس هنالك حاجه للعوده الى
التدابير الاحترازيه التس التي طلبتها
جنوب افريقيا ولكن من اجل اكمال فانني
سانق كل تدبير من هذه التدابير واثبت
بانها غير منطبقه هنا فهذا يتجاوز ما هو
ضرور ما هو ضروري لحمايه الحقوق بشكل مؤقت
وبشكل
احترازي و لكن لا تثبتوا ايا من هذه الحقو
سابدا
بالتدبير الاول
والثاني ان هذه ان هذين
التدبير يتطلبان وقفا فوريا العمليات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في غزه وهذا الطلب
هو مثير للدهشه تماما تم تقديم طلب من قبل
دوله ليست طرفا في النزاع الحالي القائم
ومن اجل وتدبر الاحترازيه تتطلب التي
تتطلب
وقفا وقفا من طرف واحد
ل وهذا يترك الطرف الاخر حرا في
مواصله
هجماته و
وقد ذكر نيه على الاستمرار في
تلك
العمليات وهذا مختلف عن قضيه التهجير فيما
يتعلق
بروسيا القانونيه العمليات العسكريه في
السياق
الروسي هي تم الاشاره اليها في اتفاقيه
روسيا زعمت ان عملياتها العسكريه كانت
تهدف الى
منع ارتكاب اباده جمعيه في اوكرانيا او
معاقبه على ذ ولكن المحكمه شككت بان
الاتفاقيه
توفر امكانيه استخدام العمل العسكري
والعمليات العسكريه من قبل طرف
واحد
ويحرم اوكرانيا من التمتع بمثل هذا الحق
ونتيجه لذلك فان التدابير الاحترازيه يمكن
ان تقود الى
حمايه
حق من اي عمل عسكريه وفي هذه الحاله
اسرائيل لا تعتمد
على على اتفاقيه ال الاباده الجماعيه
لتبرير عملياتها ان قانونيه
العمليات لا علاقه له باي تفسير او تطبيق
او تنفيذ لاحكام تلك الاتفاقيه التي
للمحكمه اختصاص بشانها فهذا الاختصاص ص
يقوم على ما ورد في الماده التاسعه من
الاتفاقيه وهنا لا تجد المحكمه ان جنوب
افريقيا او الفلسطينين في غزه لديهم حق
منطقي مشابه للقضيه الروسيه الماده 41 من
قانون هذه
المحكمه يوفر امكانيه التطبير اتخاذ
تدابير احترازيه اذا ما سمحت الظروف بذلك
وذلك من اجل الحفاظ على الحقوق حقوق ايا
من طرفي النزاع وفي حاله القضيه الروسيه
فيان وقف العمليات العسكريه ربما كان
ضروريا من اجل
الحفاظ على عدم تعرض تلك الحقوق لاي
عمليات عسكريه ولكن في هذه الحاله فان
الحق
الوارد وحسب ما تدعي وحسب ما تدعي جنوب
افريقيا فان هذا ومن السخف بمكان الايحاء
بان الطريقه الوحيده
ل التاكد من انطباق الاتفاقيه هي منع او
وقف تلك
العمليات ووفقا لجنوب افريقيا من اجل
تامين او عدم الحق مزيدا من عمليات القتل
وال وهذا يتجاوز مساله منع وقوع اباده
جمعيه يبدو ان جنوب افريقيا تحاجج ان
العمليات العسكريه ذات طبيعه عباديه ولكن
كيف يمكن لجنوب افريقيا ان تثبت هذا
الادعاء بانه على هذا النحو السيد السيد
حسيم حاجج بان هذا
ممكن ان بعض وليس بالضروره ان كل تلك
الاعمال تقع ضمن احكام تلك
الاتفاقيه كيف يمكن لبعض الافعال او
الاعمال يمكن ان
تتحول الى عمليات عسكريه الصور التي عرضت
امس لعدد من الاحداث
الفرديه ليست ادله كافيه على وجود ركن نيه
وراء العمليات العسكريه البروفيسور شو
تحدث عن ان
التصريحات التي اعتمدت عليها جنوب افريقيا
لا توفر دعاء على وجود
نيه ان المعاناه الانسانيه وسقوط الضحايا
في اي نزاع ليس بحد
ذاته سلوكا او تصرفا يمكن ان يثبت وجود
ركن اليه في العمليات تلك التدابير
الاحترازيه هي لا تقع ضمن اختصاص او سلطات
المحكمه بموجب الماده 41 من قانونها وهي
لا تهدف الى حمايه الحقوق ولا تطبيق
المعاهده في العمليات العسكريه فهي تسعى
الى وقف العمليات العسكريه وانهائها
ان التدابير المطلوبه تهدف الى عكس ما ورد
في قضيه بوسن عندما تم اصدارهم تدابير
احترازيه في تلك القضيه كانت العمليات
العسكريه مستمره والادعاءات كانت مشابهه
لما ورد في هذه القضيه او في هذه الدعوه
البوسنا والهرسك طلبت اصدار تدابير
احترازيه
تلزم صربيا من التوقف عن اي عمليات عسكريه
او شبه عسكريه ضد
المواطنين في البوسنا والهرسك ولكن
الحكومه المحكمه رفضت ذلك وحتى اليوم من
غير المحتمل
ان ان نثبت بان هنالك عمليات اباده جماعيه
مستمره ما يستدعي اصدار تدابير احترازيه
وطرفا النزاع هما طرفا طرفان في هذه
الدعوه المحكمه في ذلك في تلك القضيه رفضت
اصدار التدابير لان هذه التدابير من شان
التي تهدف الى حمايه الحقوق لا تشكل اساسا
لاصدار
حكم بشان اختصاص المحكمه في النظر في
عمليات اباده
الجمعيه وفي اي حاله فان التدابير
الاحترازيه لا يمكن ان تكون مؤشرا كما هو
الحال في هذه الدعوه بانها س
تتسبب ضررا غير قابل للجبر او عدم توفير
الحمايه حقيقه ان التدابير الاحترازيه تضع
اعباء على طرفي النزاع يتعين عليهما
التعامل معه وذلك من
اجل حمايه حقوق غير موجوده اساسا لاي من
الطرفين وهذا مناقض لسياده الدول فرض مثل
هذا العبء وهذه المسؤوليه دون
وجود دون وجود لها في الاساس وكما قال
القاضي ابراهام في قضيه المتعلقه بطلب
اصدار تدابير
احترازيه وفي القضيه الخاصه بتمويل
الارهاب القاضي توم هانكر قال انه عند
النظر في اصدار تدابير احترازيه فان فانه
من المتوقع ان تقوم
بموازنه الحقوق لكل من لكل طرف
و تطرق الى امثله تتعلق بممارسات المحكمه
والمحكمه في طلبات اصدار تدابير احترازيه
تحدثت عن الحفاظ عن ح الحقوق لكل
الاطراف وبموجب فقه المحكمه فان الماده 41
من النظام الاساسي لهذه المحكمه فان الهدف
هو حمايه الحقوق التي تدعيها الاطراف وهذا
يعني كلا الطرفين ان الاحترام ان احترام
الحقو ان الحقوق المطلوب
احترامها تتعلق
بمنطقيه
تحدي
الحقوق المتعلقه باي عمليات
تهدف التدبير الاحترازيه الى وقفها كذلك
ينبغي موازنه موازنه مصالح كل طرف عند
اصدار تدابير احترازيه
وقبل قرن في محكمه
سابقه اقرت
بمبدا ان التدابير الصادره ينبغي ان تكون
غير متناسبه و
تتجاوز
الطل القانون الدولي يؤكد على المباد
العامه
للقانون التي ينبغي ان تاخذ بها المحاكم
عند اصدارها لتدابير
مؤقته خصوصا فيما يتعلق بخطر الحاق ضرر
بالمدعي اكثر من ال المدعى عليه وهذا امر
امر تقره اليات و فض المنازعات الدوليه
الاخرى وهناك مبادئ
اخرى يمكن تطبق تطبيقها عندما تك عندما
تكون التدابير الاحترازيه لا تضر باي طرف
من اطراف النزاع او تؤثر على النتائج وان
التدابير ينبغي ان تمثل اي ضرر غير قابل
للجبر بالنسبه لطرف من اطراف الدعوه اذا
تلك المبادئ
كلها جوانب من مهام المحكمه وواجباتها
لتحقيق المساواه بين طرفي النزاع الماده
41 تشير الى ان التدابير الاحترازيه تهدف
الى الحفاظ وحمايه حقوق كل الاطراف ولا تر
تقتصر فقط على
حقوق المدعي او المدعي
و اثناء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه مع عدم مع جميع الاطراف من دون
تحفظ لو افترضنا بان كان هنالك
دوله
قدمت قضيه ضد احد الاطراف فيما يتعلق ب
الاعمال العدائيه وطلبت
تدابير مؤقته بتطلب من الحلفاء ي وقف
الاعمال العدائيه فورا عبر اظهار صور
لمعاناه المدنيين في الحرب فهل هذا سيعد
مطلبا معقولا مثل هذه التدابير كانت تتطلب
من الحلفاء ان يقوموا بالاستسلام للاعداء
بالرغم من القضيه التي امامهم قد تكون بلا
مزاعم في المستقبل ومن دون ايه اعتبار من
المحكمه فيما اذا كان هنالك ارتكاب لاباده
جماعيه من دول المحور التدابير الاحترازيه
ينغ لها حدودها وهل سيتطلب هذا من الدوله
او سيطلب من الدوله ان تقوم بتغيير نظام
حكمها او ان تصوت بطريقه مختلفه في
الجمعيه العموميه والجواب دائما يجب ان
يكون لا هل يمكن للتدابير المؤقته ان تطلب
تطلب من الدوله عن ان تمارس حقها المعقول
في الدفاع عن نفسها والجواب ايضا نفسه نفس
الجواب وفي هذه الحاله ينبغي ان يكون
هنالك ضرب توازن في المصالح من اجل تصدي ل
الاتي اولا بان حماس تعتبر منظمه ارهابيه
من قبل دوله اسرائيل ودول اخرى الامر
الثاني من دون شك بانه في السابع من
اكتوبر حماس قامت
بارتكاب عمل ارهابي كبير على الارض
الاسرائيليه وهذا مستمر الامر الثالث بان
حق اسرائيل في شن عمليات حربيه وممارسه
حقها في الدفاع عن نفسها هو معترف به في
عالميا رابعا اسرائيل ملتزمه بالالتزام
بالقانون الدولي الانساني وخامسا اسرائيل
تاخذ خطوات من اجل تخفيف المعاناه
الانسانيه ال المحمون اخرون سيتحدثون لكم
عن هذا الامر السادس هذه ليست قضيه تتطلب
منها التدابير من كلا الطرفين ان يقوموا
بقيود متبادله او التزام متبادل ولكنها
ايضا هي غير ملزمه لحماس سابعا حماس قد
وضحتها عن نيتها في الاستمرار بشن هجماتها
ضد اسرائيل وضد مواطني
اسرائيل التدابير المؤده سوف تحرم اسرائيل
من حقها في التصدي للتهديدات الامنيه ضدها
المزيد من الصواريخ يمكن اطلاقها الى
الاراضي الاسرائيل والمزيد من المدنيين
يمكن اسرهم
واغتصابهم واعمال وحشيه اخرى يمكن
ارتكابها عبر حدود غزه ولكن التدبير
المؤقته ستحضر تمنع اسرائيل من القيام
بذلك ايضا تس هذا القرار سوف يمنع يوقف
اسرائيل من ح
من ج في استعاده التحرير الاسرى وهذا
سيعطي ايضا المساحه لاسرائيل لبناء
لحماس التعبئه وبناء قدراتها واستخدام
الاسرى الاخرين كورقه
رهان
النتيجه ان منظمه متعارف عليها ارهابيه في
العالم كخلاص هي ارتكبت اعمال ووحشيه على
في دوله اسرائيل وها الان يطلب من المحكمه
ان تقوم الدوله التي هجومه عليها من ان
ترد وتسائل وتحاسب من هذه التدابير
المطلوبه لن تضع حدا ل الصراع وانما
لعمليات حربيه من طرف واحد
من الصراع وهذه تساعد الطرف الثاني وتشجع
المزيد من الهجمات الارهابيه وبهذا الصدد
وكما هو الحاله في حاله
روسيا التدابير مؤقته
ستكون
درعا لحق غير مثبت
و هنا تستخدم ايضا كسيف لاعطاء ميزه لطرف
على طرف اخر ان الضرر الذي يمكن اصلاحه
على اسرائيل هو واضح جدا وايضا
عدم تكافؤ السيده الرئيس اعضاء المحكمه ان
موقف اسرائيل بانه لا يوجد هنالك ايه اسس
لفرض للموافقه على طلب التدابير المؤقته
اتحول الان
الى السؤال الثالث والذي يطلب فيه من
اسرائيل ان تتخذ اجراءات معقوله لمنع
الاباده الجماعيه وهذا تشبيه للتدبير
الاجراء الاول في حاله ميانمار وبوسنا
وهنالك اعتراضا اخران على هذا التدبير
الاول بان صيغته غير مقيده مع العمليات
الحربيه في غزه وانما ترتبط بالشعب
الفلسطيني بالعموم وهي تفتح المجال لمطالب
مستقبليه ب و حول اسرائيل ولا علاقه بغز
بغزه وانتهاك
اسرائيل فانكن الاتفاق اي اتفاقيه الاباده
الجمعيه قد لا تكون مقتصره على ما يجري في
غزه لا يوجد هنالك ايه مبرر للتدابير
المؤقته لتتجاوز
الدعوه نفسها وهذا الاعتراض ايضا
يرتبط على يرتبط
بالطلب
الاحتراز الرابع
والسابع
و لم يعطى اي سبب لهذه التدابير المؤقته
الرابع والسابع
و ان تقول جنوب افريقيا بان الفشل في
الوفاء
بالتزام موجب اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
هذه
التدابير
اسرا تطلب جنوب
افريقيا العمل بموجب الاتفاقيه لحمايه
الشعب الفلسطيني لكن جنوب افريقيا قد تحدد
بان هذه
التدابير قد تحقق هذه
الحقوق وفي هذه القضيه غير مبر
والتدبير الثالث لا ينبغي ان يتم منح ايضا
من التدابير المؤقته انتقل الان الى
التدبير الاحتياطي الرابع الذي يطلب من
اسرائيل التوقف عن ارتكاب اعمال بموجب
الماده الثال الموجب
الثانيه اولا بانه لا يوجد هنالك في حاله
بوزنا وميانمار لا يوجد هنالك من هو طرف
اخر فما الفائده من هذه التدابير لا يوجد
هنالك اي مبرر الامر الثاني تستخدم كلمه
الامتناع
والذي ولا تثبت بان هنالك انتهاك لفا
الاتفاقيه من قبل اسرائيل وفي حاله
البوزن لم يتم منح هذه
التدابير
المؤقته وايضا ان تمتنع يوغسلافيا عن جميع
اشكال الاباده الجماعيه اي هنالك امر على
يلزم الدول على الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب
الاتفاقيه
اذا ما اثبتت فشل الدوله بالالتزام
بذلك مثل
هذه القرارات قد تقوم بتشويه سمعه
الدول ومن دون احقيه بموجب الماده 41 من
من النظام الاساسي لاتفاقيه الاباد
الجماعيه الان
وبالرغم ان هذا الاجراء ليس ضمن ليس بموجب
الماده
41 ان الصياغه المقدمه من جنوب افريقيا
تحاجج بان كانت هنالك وجود نيه لارتكاب
الاباده الجماعيه وهذا
التفسير يقصد منه ايقاف العمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وكل قتل
ل مسلحه يواجه اسرائيل سوف يعتبر اذا
انتهاكا لهذا التدبير حتى التفتيش الامني
لقوات الاسرائيليه لدخول المساعدات
الانسانيه الى غزه
وبموجب القانون الدولي
الانساني متعارف عليه في قرار مجلس الامن
272 قد ايضا يحاجج على انه انتهاك اخر
والطلب اذا لهذا التدبير المؤقت يجب ان
يتم رفضه كما هو الحال مع التدبير الاول
والثاني اتحدث الان عن الطلب
التدبير الخامس والذي يتطلب اعتبار بعض
الافعال بانها تصعب شروط ظروف الحياه
وتتسبب بدمار مادي مرتبط ايضا بتدبير
المؤقت الرابع وهذا ايضا نعترض عليه اولا
لانه هو ليس تدبيرا مستقلا واذا كان
التدبير الرابع لم لا ينطبق فبالتالي
الخامس كذلك الحال الامر الثاني لا يوجد
في حاله ميانمار والبوسنه اي شبيه
وبالتالي لا حاجه لتدبير مؤقت جديد ومجددا
يتم استخدام كلمه
الامتناع فعلى سبيل
المثال كان هنالك الحديث عن التهجير
القصري وطد فصين من منازلهم وهذه
اشاره الى ما تقوم به اسرائيل منطلب
المدنيين من الانتقال مؤقتا الى مككن
بعيده عن الخطر وهذا القصد
منه الحمايه
المدنيين وهذا الطلب ل ليس لا يعتبر ولا
يصل الى مستوى التهجير
القصري وج افريق تقول بانه على اس تمتنع
عن تحدير
المدنيين قبل شن عملياتها العسكريه
والفقره جيم
تتحدث عن ان الضرر على المباني من
العمليات العسكريه هو غير قانوني ايضا وفق
القانون الدولي الانساني
ويرتقي الى مستوى تدمير حياه المدنيين في
غزه وفقا ايضا للفقره جيم من هذا التدبير
والفقره ج من التدبير المؤقت الثالث يسعى
طل قرار
الحكومه فيما
يتعلق بالتهجير القصري وتدمير منازل
المدنيين وتعريض حياتهم الى الخطر ان الحق
واقع هو بان الصراع والوضع الانساني لا
يمكن حله بين لله وضعاها وهذا التدبير
المؤقت يبد صمم لتكون
اسرائيل في انتهاك له مع ايجاده
وهذا يعتبر
ضررا ولا يجب يتم منحه ايضا اما الطلب
السادس المطلوب والل وهو مستقل وهذا يطلب
من اسرائيل ان تتاكد من ان
جيشها لا
يرتكب احداثا تنتهك البندين الثاني
والثالث من اتفاقيه الاباده الجماعيه
وايضا هنالك احاله ايضا او اشاره
لقضيه بوزنا وميانمار ولكن الاعتراض هو
الى ايه مرجعيه لايه وحدات عسكريه او
افراد
عمل لهم علاقه مباشره مع اسرائيل او
يتاثرون بها وطبعا هذا تم نسخه من التدبير
المؤقت الثاني في قضيه ميانمار
والبوسنه وهو يزعم وجود قوات غير نظاميه
وايضا التشبيه غير مناسب في هذه الحاله
ولا يوجد ايه اشاره الى قوات غير قوات
الدفاع الاسرائيليه والتي هي ملتزمه
بالقانون الدولي
الانساني
الجزء الثاني من التدبير المؤقت السادي
والي
تضرب التزام المعاقبه مرتكبي الاباده
الجماعيه لم يتم الاشاره الى هذا لا في
بوسنا ولا ميانماري
ومعاقبه الاباده الجماعيه ينبغي ان يتم
القيام به
فورا من اجل حمايه هذا ل تمنحه اما
التدبير السابع يتضمن ايضا اجرائ منفصلين
الاول الطلب من اسرائيل اتخاذ اجراءات لمن
تدمير الادله اولاف الادله والمحكمه قد
اشارت لمثل هذا في مناسبتين ولكنها لم
ترفض استخدامه في مناسبتين
اخريين وفي الحاله التي منحت فيها تطبيق
التدابير المؤقته بشكل محدد من منطلق بان
الادله قد اخفيت او اتلفت وهنا في هذه
الحاله جنوب افريقيا تحدث مبعث قلق حقيقيه
عن تدمير الادله وتاثيرها على تحقيقات
مستق بليه
وجرائم ان جنوب
افريقيا تشير الى او تكتر العمليات
العسكريه نفسها هي بحد ذاتها تدمير للادله
وهي بحاجه الى تدمير ايضا تطلب فيه ايقاف
العمليات العسكريه ان منح هذا
التدبير
تدبير سوف هو من لا اساس له و يسبب ضررا
للسمعه الشق الثاني من هذا التدبير يطلب
من اسرائيل عدم اعاقه وصول لجان تقصي
الحقائق الى الى غزه ومع هذا لقد اشرنا
بان امكانيه الوصول الى غزه هي تحت سيطره
مصر مصول وان
اسرائيل الامر ان التدبير المؤقت لهذا
الاجراء طلب طلب في حاله مينمار ولم يتم
منح من قبل المحكمه الحاجه الى هذا
التدبير لم يتم اثباتها الطلب الثامن هو
من اسرائيل ان تقوم برفع تقارير منتظمه
الى
المحكمه حول التدابير المؤقته
وتنفيذها ومجددا مثل هذا الطلب رفض في
حالات مشابه وقض
وهذا يعرض او يثبت بان مثل هذه الطلبات لا
يتم الموافق عليها بطريقه الروتينيه وفي
حاله ارمينيا ضد اذربيجاني
المحكمه قررت بان
التقرير
ضروري
و جنوب افريقيا لم تبرر الحاجه لمثل هذا
التدبير ولا يوجد نقص للمواد الاسرائيليه
والتقارير حول الوضع الحالي في غزه واخيرا
الطلب التاسع
هو طلب
غير استفزازي لانه
يطلب هو ليس من العرف
وافريقيا افريقيا لا تبرر
ضرورته التدبير لعدم
الاستفزازي يرتبط بالطرفين
السراع ومثل هذا التدبير هنا
ينطبق على طرف واحد و هنا في ميانمار حال
قضيه ميانمار لم يعطى مثل هذا
التدبير وهنا لا يمكن فرضه اذا على طرف
واحد في قضيه او حتى اذا منح هذا الطلب
فان جنوب افريقيا سو تبقى حره
في ولا تمنع اسرائيل حماس من تصعيدها مع
حماس الهدف من هذا كله ومنع اسرائيل
بالاستجابه لايه استفزازات
وتصعيد سيدتي الرئيسه اعضاء المحكمه
الموقرين بهذا اختتم حجتي حول عدم مناسبه
هذه التدابير المؤقته التي تطلبها جنوب
افريقيا واشكركم على حسن اصغاء وادعو